claro siempre ocurre un hecho como este
de raúl hay que ser muy prudente pero
obviamente las alarmas saltaron cuando
se supo que había un ataque cerca de la
antigua sede de charlie hebdo hay que
decir que la sede actual de este
periódico satírico no se conoce está en
el amplio secreto por lo tanto el lugar
más simbólico donde sobre todo hay un
mural con los rostros de los que
fallecieron ese día de enero del año
2015 es esa sede que ha sido atacada hoy
o que en realidad no fue atacada porque
fue muy cerca de allí que ocurrieron los
ataques pero las personas que son
víctimas de este ataque a los dos
heridos pertenecen a una sociedad de
producción que está instalada en ese
mismo edificio que habían bajado a tomar
un cigarro entonces obviamente se hace
la relación sobre todo como tú decías
hace un mes comenzó ese juicio donde hay
14 acusados 11 presente 3 que están en
la ausencia y que están acusados
justamente de haber ayudado
materialmente o intelectualmente a los
tres atentados que hubo en enero del
2015 el atentado contra ya aliento pero
también
contra el supermercado calle de la
puerta de avance ni contra una policía
en la comuna de movus y desde que
comenzó ese juicio ese mismo día la
revista publicó nuevamente las
caricaturas de mahoma esto fue visto
como una provocación hubo inmediatamente
amenazas de parte de al qaeda y de
incluso reacciones de países de mayoría
musulmana después hubo las amenazas como
decías tú contra la directora de
recursos humanos directamente que
obligaron a que ella dejara su domicilio
viviera temporalmente en otro sitio y
esta mañana también se dijo que se había
encontrado un paquete sospechoso en el
mismo domicilio que podría también tener
relación con el ataque de hoy por lo
tanto no se puede no se puede obviar
toda esta actualidad lo dijo el mismo
fiscal antiterrorista de parís que ha
sido no es cierto convocado para llevar
esta investigación junto a la policía
judicial
raúl así es erika y por ahí también
entonces fueron las declaraciones del
fiscal de parís y el primer ministro por
eso también yo sacaba a colación en este
caso
que vimos en el 2015 en charlie hebdo y
además también que el director de ese
medio luego de que se publicara
nuevamente está a estas alturas en
contra el profeta mahoma y en el marco
de este juicio él afirmó que defendía la
libertad de prensa y que iba a continuar
publicando a lo que ellos les parecía
conveniente publicar en su revista erika
y con toda esta situación entonces de
seguridad que vemos en la capital
francesa le pregunto cómo puede afectar
esto a la gente en parís
bueno obviamente que cualquier ataque de
este tipo es algo que despierta un poco
la angustia entre la ciudadanía que como
recordaba el ministro del interior de
armani al comienzo de este juicio la
amenaza sigue siendo muy alta
extremadamente alta decía él en parís y
en francia y los franceses son
consciente de ellos además estamos en
una época complicada debido ya a la
crisis sanitaria no es cierto en que
estamos viviendo una segunda ola en que
hay la posibilidad de un nuevo
confinamiento entonces son tiempos
complicados y obviamente en la
actualidad del juicio abierto lo que
significa revivir ese momento duro no
solo para la gente que obviamente
resultaron lamentablemente heridas o que
perdieron a familiares pero en general
para la ciudad de parís es un momento
traumático recordemos que incluso la
alcaldesa de parís fue a testimoniar a
este juicio un testimonio por cierto
polémico pero ese es un momento
traumático para la ciudad para quienes
vivimos aquí y por lo tanto que hay un
ataque implica revivir todos esos malos
recuerdos